the Democrats are definitely not as
screwy as we are and I think they're not
screwy at all actually in the Democratic
party they raise money in a very
disciplined way and uh you know they do
have their little tiffs personality tips
between the squad and Nancy Pelosi but
overall I think they're very disciplined
and now for the first couple of years I
was at the RNC we would be cheering
rah-rah because we raised more money
into the RNC than the DNC Rises into the
DNC and they're quietly laughing because
they raised 10 times as much money as we
do but they raise it into the NAACP and
the ACLU and the Michigan welfare rights
Association and La Raza and La Familia
Vota those five organizations or
organizations that I'm up against in
court right now uh for for election
litigation that's not the DNC they have
dark money organizations that influence
our elections and help pick
right-wing candidates in moderate
districts and so that we just like we
are we're cooked we're thinking great we
selected this great Conservative
candidate
that candidate can't win in that state
and so we're just like not even talking
about that so their their monetary
ecosystem is far superior to ours and
they're very disciplined and we are not
and we need to get smart
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder of Dylan Law Group an
absolute Free Speech Warrior I'm talking
First Team all free speech Warrior and
now candidate for the Republican
National committee chair harmeet Dylan
harmeet welcome back to the Reuben
report thanks for having me I'm glad to
have you harmeet and we haven't spoken
in a while at least on air uh and I
thought you would be the perfect guest
to be our last guest of 2022 because one
of the main messages that I'm always
pushing on this show is that good people
have to get involved and just in the
last couple weeks you have thrown your
hat in the ring and you're getting
involved so my first question I suppose
is are you nuts
yeah this question has been asked to me
by several people who love me and you
know
there come if I'm sure Dave you've had
them where you were like hey let me go
start this new thing or let me leave
this cozy thing I have and follow my
dream I had that when I I've had that a
few times in my life and I I kind of
felt struck by that so I you know
discussed it with my husband we prayed
over it and you know we decided yes you
feel in your heart you have to stand up
and challenge what's going on at the RNC
because you cannot stand by and just nod
and have you know another shrimp
cocktail and pretend like everything is
going well when it's not and so that's
really I really felt compelled I've kind
of felt that way for the last couple of
years in fact but you know after the
2020 election debacle uh president Trump
endorsed Rana
McDaniel for a third term and you know
that itself was a was something that a
lot of folks thought well maybe it was
time for new leadership then not that it
was her fault but when you were in
charge and perhaps you don't you know
quite pivot and respond to changing
election laws and other issues and
messaging
maybe it's time for a Fresh Approach
well you know we didn't have that and so
she did promise in her last run that she
was going to have a third and final term
and then suddenly surprisingly she said
she's going to run for a fourth term and
so I said wait a minute we have not won
and what I call the definition of
winning and three successive election
Cycles I mean here in California 2018
was a Wipeout we had a it was like we
lost half an obligation
2020 we lost the White House we lost the
house we barely clung to the Senate 2022
we're barely clinging to the house such
that there is a leadership race that has
met conservative members of Congress
calling each other names on Twitter
that's and airing their dirty laundry
out in public and and we're saying yeah
let's sign up for another two years of
this and another election cycle America
can't afford for us to continue to be
behind the eight ball and playing catch
up with Democrats we just can't and so
if nothing changes
we are going to expect the same thing
and I I for one don't want to be sitting
here twiddling my thumbs well we're 10
20 years behind the Democrats and we
don't have to be because you know Dave
you know there's so much energy in our
movement there's so many smart young and
middle-aged people outside DC uh people
who who are social media savants people
who are fluent with the culture people
who get that the base of our party has
shifted from neocon cold war warriors
and Chamber of Commerce messaging and
tax cuts for the rich to blue collar
workers and young people who are
energized about the future and want to
have a home and a family
um we are out of touch and I don't think
we need to be so I'm here to bring us
back into touch and have that attempt to
reform the RNC into fitting what the
base of the party is okay so I want to
unpack all that including some of the
Republican infighting and everything
else that you touched on there but
before we do all of that for for anyone
in my audience that hasn't seen you on
the show before or isn't that familiar
can we do a little harm meet 101 real
quick why did I describe you as a free
speech Warrior
well I've been doing
litigation literally since before I was
a lawyer
Dartmouth at age 16 I grew up in rural
North Carolina and at Dartmouth I became
the editor-in-chief of the famous
Dartmouth Review newspaper that Dinesh
D'Souza Laura Ingram and many you know
now famous people on the right have been
part of and during that time uh three of
my colleagues were actually kicked out
of Dartmouth for something they wrote
about a professor and so back in the day
the American civil liberties Union used
to actually care about free speech and
they sent us a lawyer who who helped us
Sue Dartmouth so at the age of 19 I was
on 60 Minutes talking about Free Speech
issues on American campuses we won my
friends got reinstated set me off of my
pre-med course into a career in law and
so ever since I graduated from law
school now almost 30 years ago I've been
working on issues of Liberty and since I
started my own Law Firm we have focused
a lot on Free Speech issues in virtually
every context but we're well known for
our work
media censorship through Twitter a
couple of times three times where you
know just representing half of
conservative social media you know we
represent reporters who are sued by
politicians we represented the daily
wire in litigation in the United States
Supreme Court
um and you know project Veritas we've
stood up for their rights in court and
so it's it's a real honor because it's
really the epitome for me the first
amendment is first for a reason and it's
it's it's something so special compared
to the rest of the world even the
English-speaking World they don't have a
First Amendment we have that and so it's
a it's a passion to do that work and
probably a third of the lawyers at my 22
lawyer firm do that work and it's really
exciting yeah and I want to give you a
little credit publicly that I've given
you privately which is that over the
years when I've had a lot of crazy hit
pieces written about me I've called you
a couple times particularly the one with
the New York Times when they basically
on the cover said I'm the head of the
alt-right and I was like you know can I
sue them and whatever and and you calmly
explained to me that unfortunately in
the world we live in even with our
liable and slander laws like it's tough
it's tough and it'll probably cost you
way more than it'll cost this giant
Corporation so you've you've talked me
off the ledge once or twice so I owe you
for that
yeah absolutely and and look now I don't
care for the record they keep doing it
and it's like now it's kind of funny to
me but years ago yeah you're bigger than
them and so what you know so that that
you know like believe me in fact the RNC
has been peddling hit pieces about me
and it's very upsetting but luckily I'm
surrounded by calm people who are like
the truth is there you'll Prevail and so
so it's all it's all good but
um you know
to leave a job that I'm very passionate
about two jobs I also started a
non-profit people who can't afford or
you know for other reasons they need pro
bono legal help for for free and that is
a very you know active nonprofit Center
for American Liberty we represent
children who are targeted by transgender
groomers we represent
um people in free speech issues we
represent a host of other civil rights
issues and to leave that in my Law Firm
which does the favorite part of law that
most lawyers would kill to be able to do
all day and get paid for it that's how
passionate I feel about this RNC thing
I mean I love my job right now I love my
jobs but I love America more than that
and I think that we're just driving this
thing off a cliff here and we can't
afford it so nobody else stepped up so I
stepped up I mean Lee zeldon talked
about it but ultimately didn't want to
take on the challenge because it is a
challenge and I stepped up so I'm I'm
gonna I'm gonna see it through
all right so before we get into all of
that Nitty Gritty that you mentioned
earlier just a little bit more on on the
big Tech stuff and Free Speech because
obviously we're seeing all of the
Twitter files dumping right now at the
same time we're also seeing the
mainstream Media or the corporate press
whatever you want to call them we're
seeing them completely ignore it so our
Divergence between the people that
believe one thing and the people that
believe another thing is just getting
wider and wider and wider do you think
anything will actually come out of these
leaks I mean beyond the fact that a
certain amount of people will wake up do
you think that there will be legal
action either against the U.S government
or further action against Twitter and
and does that then push things down so
that uh you know down the road so that
YouTube and Google and Facebook and
everybody else might start getting
looked at in a different way as well
well there is action against the US
government and Eric Schmidt attorney
general and and some others are filing
suit before the Twitter files came out
my law firm and the center for American
Liberty sued Twitter and a host of other
parties including California Secretary
of State for this very thing and they
um it was revealed after the 2020
election that California my government
right which I pay a lot of taxes to was
using those tax dollars enemies along
the enemies as our client Rogan o'hanley
AKA DC Drano who was just reinstated on
Twitter last week our lawsuit is ongoing
that kind of litigation is ongoing but
the courts are not receptive to it at
this time you know we lost that case in
the district court we argued in the
ninth circuit you win or lose based on
the perspective of the judges who are on
the court frankly so what is needed in
my opinion to really reform the
situation is for Republicans to win
elections Republicans have to win
elections and it has to be the right
Republicans if you actually had the you
know
out of touch crew who's in the
Republican Congress and Senate right now
those were the same people who were in
The Republican Congress and Senate when
we had the White House in 2017 and 2018
those were the leaders they did nothing
to address social media censorship we
need to elect new and better Republicans
who get it we need to reform
Communications decency act section 230
to not allow basically a free pass to
all kinds of torts and contract
violations that courts are ignoring
under the Aegis of 230 and then we need
to create in my opinion of social media
users what do you say to the counter
argument on the 230 argument we've
discussed that a lot on the show that
certain some people will say well if you
take away some of those protections that
then you'll actually hamper Free Speech
because the platforms will feel that
they are more responsible and then
they'll have to go after everybody to
make sure everything's you know clean or
okay yeah
I don't I I'm not advocating the removal
of 230. I don't I don't agree with that
there's a provision of it that says that
uh social media companies can remove
content that is quote unquote otherwise
objectionable so it isn't in an
enumerated list they use that otherwise
objectionable to say uh vaccine
information that's contrary to what
fauci says they use that as an excuse to
censor things that they the social media
company want to suppress or manipulate
or worse as we're learning through the
Twitter files they let our government do
that without disclosing it no I do not
think that was the meaning of section
230 at all and Congress can make that
clear the law is old 1996 law passed to
actually protect social media companies
it's an out of control monster and one
of the reasons that Dave that you say
that you know there's sort of a lack of
responsiveness by the mainstream media
on these issues the mainstream media has
actually been crippled by Dent of the
social media companies having rights and
privileges to say and do whatever they
want whereas the traditional media
doesn't have those rights and privileges
in a way CDA 230 has really weaponized
the growth of these the the the
unaccountability of these big social
media companies
um and so I think there are some tweaks
that could be done without empowering
the government empowering the users
there should be a social media users
Bill of Rights that says that if they
change the terms on you if they ban you
or suppress you for reasons that they
did not disclose in advance you have a
right to sue them we have rights like
that with respect to pharmaceutical
products products that blow up cars that
don't work we have those rights with
commercial products this is a commercial
product I'm paying to use Twitter I
should have some rights with respect to
Twitter
so what would you say I I've actually I
know you do some work obviously with Ron
Coleman who's been on the show many
times
um and we discussed this once on air if
I was to find out for example that the
government directly had contacted
Twitter to take down the tweet that I
had back in July of 2021 saying that
vaccine mandates were coming and
vaccines were not working uh as they as
promised etc etc
if I was to find out if through these
Twitter files or whatever it might be
that that actually it was because of a
government agent telling Twitter to take
it down what is what is the reward for
someone other than that maybe the
government would acknowledge it can you
sue the government like can you be like
whoa I want 10 million bucks because you
guys infringe on my free speech or is it
just purely just yeah we screwed up it's
back up and nobody gets fired this is
the government
well we have been suing the government
the case I just described is like that
and in the ninth circuit I think we
round into a uh let's just say we
haven't received the ruling yet but it
was not a favorable reception in the
ninth circuit I pray that in fact at the
end of the day these Twitter files
actually started to come out after the
hearing and so maybe you know the clerks
and the judges will see that wait whoa
this is actually a huge deal it isn't
this isn't a one-off this is actually a
whole system that's been exposed
a case like that filed in a different
Court might have succeeded but actually
under Twitter's terms of service you
have to file it here in California you
know so it's it's it's been a challenge
I'm confident that over time there will
be a case that breaks through that says
that this is a violation of the first
amendment I do think it is there are
some First Amendment lawyers who say oh
no the companies can do whatever they
want it was merely a strong suggestion
from the government but here right right
files Twitter was actually being paid by
the FBI I mean I don't know how you can
deny that that's government action it's
it's government action obviously so I'm
sorry I'm very animated about it but I'm
shocked that judges aren't picking this
up right well also if the government was
to call me if I got a call from a
government agent saying Dave we're not
telling you to do anything but just FYI
we've been watching the show and you've
been saying a lot about that I might
take that as a as a threat or some sort
of yeah that's why the the gray area
here obviously is where the the real
stuff is right I mean or you know nice
social media presence and show you have
shame if something were to happen to it
or you know maybe there's an audit you
know like literally the government has
so much power over us
um we're seeing it with January 6th
stuff I mean they can
be crime and harass you and so this is
not trivial to me and by the way I as a
First Amendment lawyer I would stand up
for the rights of some leftists to be
able to say whatever they want on social
media
short of threats of violence that are
true threats or other violations of
enumerated parts of the 230 pornography
and things like that
um
but that does not seem to be reciprocal
the left has entirely abandoned the
principle of due process equal
protection for speech issues on the
right the ACLU no longer supports Free
Speech they don't they don't support you
being able to talk about gun use I mean
it is it is a 180 and it is just a
wholly awoke
woke Endeavor now and so we the right
have become the engine of free speech
and even on our side people don't get it
so I'd love to see a whole Revolution on
our side about these issues
okay so speaking of a revolution now
let's talk about what what your plans
are to do with the Republicans one of
the lines that I say on this show all
the time is you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
and I I think that's really resonated
with an awful lot of people that the
Democrats have lost their mind the
Republicans it's messy they're going to
fail you sometimes but at least there's
something there to work with so what
would your vision be of what the
Republican Party would truly stand for
you hit on a little bit of it earlier
but what's what's the real Vision that
that you want to sell to the party well
first of all you should be a republican
if you're not a Democrat
you should not I feel like that let me
just put that on the table um it is a
zero-sum game they're two parties that
are relevant in this country and if
you're not winning you're losing that's
that's the fact of politics Okay so
um with respect to what I would do
differently they're I mean we probably
don't even have time here but look the
the party has evolved in a certain
direction it's really been the same to
people running it for the last 12 years
the base of the party is revolute has
changed in a revolutionary way during
those 12 years some of the same staff
from the reince priebus era of six years
are still running the show at the RNC
today and guess what those staff are
doing they're negotiating contracts that
are self-interested hundreds of millions
of dollars has flown into the pockets of
consultants over the last few years and
we haven't won elections the Democrats
don't operate that way the Democrats
smartened up after losing elections and
paying a bunch of money to Consultants
almost 20 years ago and they said no no
we're not going to do that anymore the
party will only do the stuff that only
the party can do and the party is plays
a very important role they have certain
uh role with respect to sharing data
with State parties with respect to
fundraising with respect to you know
worries they have certain role but a lot
of the stuff the Democrats do is outside
the party they do it in non-profits
pseudo nonprofits Pacs and whatever but
still the messaging is led by a party
apparatus that is disciplined
on focused on messaging and on their
goals they do not you know have little
disputes with each other in the in the
press and members of Congress attacking
each other that doesn't happen or they
have a party discipline and they
ruthlessly collect money and dump it
into our races and we sit here and say
as a Republican party oh sorry I will
say we can't do anything about that I'm
not saying that the party should be
picking candidates in a primary but what
I am saying is you're foolish if you let
the Democrats pick your candidates in
the primary we have no plan for that the
election laws were changed on a
wholesale basis in 2012
increment for that our party was not
raising or spending money on Election
litigation we were like oh oh there's an
election let's have some itinerant you
know temp lawyers put down their laptops
and work like a lawyer militia and work
for free to save elections for two weeks
and then go back to their jobs it
doesn't work that way we have jobs we
have commitments you can't just like
make me work for free for two weeks so
we have to have been investing like the
Democrats did in lawyers like Mark Elias
who has funded to the tune of whatever
he wants and files frivolous lawsuits
sometimes and just spams the courts with
nonsense lawsuits but they get through
and they win if there's no opposition we
have not been doing that until the last
two years I will say the chair listen to
me jumping up and down and screaming
about it we began to invest in that
issue we're still way behind
our cost of fundraising Dave is out of
control it's like 40 percent okay I just
came from a turning point USA event
turning points cost of fundraising now
it's a non-profit
seven percent or so they raise hundreds
of millions of dollars over the same
time period that we have
where's that other 30 going what's going
on there it's going into the pockets of
people who are not helping us win
elections I'm very passionate about this
little donors Mom and Pops people like
my my parents and my you know other
relatives they say oh Lindsey Graham
needs money you know let's give him some
money I like him I saw him on television
and suddenly they're like signed up
forever to keep getting emails from
every Republican in the universe and
they can't stop it
the puppy will die you know your mom
will be held hostage like the messages
are so abusive and then big dollar
donors are really sick of giving their
five million 10 million 50 million
dollar checks and we don't win elections
I mean that's not what they're there for
so pretty much nobody is satisfied with
the status quo except
a significant percentage of the members
of the Republican National Committee who
have their power their privilege their
title their Prestige their photographs
of politicians I'm not there for that
I'm here to win elections so I can go
back and enjoy my life and so
um
we would be making one of the things
that really ratcheted up the ugliness in
this race Dave will be very interesting
to know that I think on day three of my
campaign I tweeted that I would initiate
a top to bottom audit of every
Consulting and vendor contract at the
RNC and before that it was a very
genteal exchange of ideas and isn't it
cute that our meets running suddenly
every political consultant in DC is out
for my blood placing hit pieces
um
but it's all going to come out it's all
going to come out it's been going on
there and then we can talk about what we
do about it because the Democrats don't
have this rotten corrupt system that
like we do and look a lot of people in
our RNC most of them are well-meaning
but they don't control what's going on
there and so I think I've had some
conversations with members who've been
shocked to hear what I've said and I
think I changed their minds because you
know it's a very top-down organization
the RNC tells the states if you want us
to subsidize a particular walk app or
method of fundraising when read you have
to use our system
no choice we don't give you a choice as
to what works better in your state
that's not Republican the Republican is
is pushing power down to the people it's
respecting the people it's not calling
them names some of my fellow members of
these are
called voters low information bitchers
for daring to contact them about this
leadership race I love hearing from
those voters I don't call them names
like that they're voters they may be
angry sometimes they are but they're
angry for a good reason because they're
Republicans and we don't want elections
so of course they're angry I'm angry so
um I think it is with a relatively
simple platform that I've been laying
out as I'm talking to the 168 167 other
voters but I'm also sharing that with
the with the public and there is
virtually no support for the current
leadership outside the RNC and the
consultant class who who feed off of us
and so that's been heartening and so one
way or the other we're going to see
change at the RNC right I mean I agree
with the premise there it doesn't seem
like there's a lot of support there but
for whatever reason and people can call
it the swamp or the the Deep state or
whatever the hell it is it does keep
going so The Outsiders like you always
have that that uphill battle I I see
sort of two parts of this you're talking
about sort of the under the hood
technical stuff like that that are the
problems in terms of voting and what's
going on with fundraising but I think
there's also the ideal level that it
seems like there's a real problem
Brewing just in the last couple days uh
I heard Mitch McConnell say that the
number one issue on Republicans Minds uh
is defending Ukraine from Russia and I
thought man you know I'm for the first
time in my life since I moved to Florida
I registered as a republican but I think
the ideas I talk about resonate with a
lot of people on both sides it's like
that's not in my top 20. and the way he
said it I thought man I can now see why
Republican you know the OG Republicans
have just had it with you guys what do
you do about the messaging part that
seems very disconnected when he could be
talking about I don't know the economy
the Border
Free Speech Etc
well I can't do anything about Mitch
McConnell if I if I were in the United
States Senate I'd be voting for a
different leader
I can't do anything about the leadership
race in the house where because we
didn't do that well there was no Red
Wave you have this infighting that's
just awful friends of mine are throwing
stones at each other
unfortunate but I can do something about
the RNC and the RNC does set the
messaging and unfortunately we've been
kind of Hostage to whatever happened
recently whatever the Democrats said
recently we're always like reacting to
that we don't seem to be going back to
our platform or our basic values or
frankly even taking a poll and then
talking about what Republicans actually
care about
um we spend Millions during this chairs
tenure there have been millions of
dollars spent on Consultants on
messaging issues believe it or not and
what you see is the result of that uh
it's not very good messaging I'm sorry
to say sorry to offend the people who
are probably going to be very angry and
set out more hit pieces about me because
of that but it's true our base does not
like or appeal the messaging did not
turn out voters the candidates did not
turn out voters and and we sat there
like sitting ducks spending a bunch of
money on them and you know somebody's
can't like I said back to the issue the
left to find our candidates we're
letting that happen because we're not
doing a good job of picking them and
defining them there's no party maybe
there needs to be more of a like cabal
situation where you get get together and
say look guys we're not going to win in
Georgia we're not going to win in
Pennsylvania we're not going to win in
the state or that state if we don't have
a candidate who fits this profile that
means our data has to be good our um our
messaging has to be good we have to have
enough money and we have to be doing
litigation Around the Clock
election Integrity is not a seasonal
itinerant worker deal it happened I mean
you know RNC is laid off most of its
election Integrity Staff after the
election as if they're like we picked
the crop and now we're done no no we
need to be doing we are so far behind
the left we need to be doing this for a
decade or two to until we reverse the
tide and we need to be spending 10x what
we're spending on it does it seem sort
of too black pilled to you when people
say well look you've got California the
most populous state in in the union and
it's one party at this point and it's
over and it's corrupt we know just kind
of let it be I mean I tried I tried I
could not take it any anymore I don't
know if you know this by the way Army
three days after the recall election
that obviously I was helping Larry Elder
with I was audited by the state
coincidentally the same day that I sold
my house or put my house for sale
um but what do you say to that like the
people that are just like no we just
have to concede the ground of some of
these states because it it the Machinery
is so entrenched
well I can see the ocean from my home
and that's why I live in California and
we got an ocean here in Florida you know
it's a different ocean but it's pretty
good you know the Pacific is more
beautiful Florida's great too but I
don't like those giant bugs you have
over there but um but but but seriously
no we cannot see in any part of America
to the left and look I mean those of us
who are who didn't get the memo were
still like fighting Vine Enemy Lines
here like it was World War II and we
weren't told the war was over some of us
are still fighting that that war here we
picked up seats in in the house in
California
old-fashioned work
John Duarte I raised 100 000 for John
Duarte our new member of Congress in
California hey you know he's from a
farming Community he's a farming he's a
farmer go figure you know you picked a
candidate who's like like the district
he's a good communicator who's authentic
he had the money because people like me
and others helped him raise the money
that the RNC did invest in California to
helping targeted districts and we we the
party at California pulled that off okay
so I think there are a lot of factors
that contributed to that that's good
because we went from 14 seats in 2016 to
seven seats in 2018. my God that was a
Wipeout and then we've slowly built back
even as we've lost a congressional seat
so no it's not hopeless but
I mean
the recall was kind of sad
um Larry Elder was a dynamic candidate
and all of that getting your campaign
started at the last minute and and never
having run for office before and the
first thing you run for advocate for
that
I definitely think that people should
learn the ropes we've been encouraging
people here in California in this
election cycle to step up and run for
school board are you a mom or a dad
you're upset with what's going on school
board is not very expensive to run for
it's easy to campaign for it's a small
Universe of Voters and we had some
success in that regard we have to be
training people to do that I've run for
office twice unlike the current chair I
actually know what it means to actually
like stand out there put your money
where your mouth is and actually stand
at the at the BART the subway station
hand out cards talk to hostile groups of
people raise money from strangers it's a
skill set that you cannot just get
because you have great ideas it is a it
is a craft so I think it I think that we
need to have and we had a good another
good candidate the mayor of San Diego
and you know once Larry came in was very
popular that was just that race was just
over but I don't think Larry had had
built the team necessary to win and so
um George gascon recall okay in Los
Angeles that should have succeeded I
believe it bungled because of
Consultants Consultants who did the
signature Gathering did not do their
jobs correctly and there was no
transparency around that and now it's
degenerated into investigations and all
of that what a tragedy but here in San
Francisco in a liberal City we got rid
of the school board we got rid of our
district attorney so there is a point at
which even liberals even even 12 avocado
toast eating liberals will say no more I
don't want feces in front of my hip Loft
condo I'm done so yes I do think that we
are that they're persuadable yeah George
gascon who you mentioned just for people
that don't know he's the former D.A of
San Francisco who ruined San Francisco
then moved down to La Bernie backed of
course basically ruined LA and then the
recall against it fell but as you
referenced the the recall of boudin in
San Francisco that one actually worked
have you seen any changes in San
Francisco is there any chance that
because they got rid of some of these
guys and have I suppose slightly less
crazed Lefty is that things are going to
get better
I would call I would describe it as a
marginal change to in the but but from
the D.A is much better she's talking
about Prosecuting crime she has
Prosecuting crimes I don't think we're
gonna I mean at the depth of earlier
this year case of boudin's uh tenure
elderly Asians were regularly getting
stabbed assaulted knocked over killed
with no prosecution that's not happening
anymore I haven't read a single story
like that since Brooke Jenkins became
the district attorney she's probably a
Democrat I don't know it's a nonpartisan
race but whatever I voted for her
because you know she she was the person
who's most likely to succeed and and I
live here and so it matters to me it's
you know I I have to call the police
sometimes over threats that are made to
me I really want there to be a district
attorney who who cares about that stuff
so I think she's an improvement
um could we want would I one day like to
vote for a republican for that race
absolutely but you know I'll take I'll
take a better Democrat where that's the
only choice so I think that's a good
development
um now
we have to keep it up but San Francisco
has been absolutely not that's not the
point of your question but this city is
so hollowed out and decimated by the
combination of coveted lockdowns work
from home Twitter and other big
companies packing up and leaving it is
it is not the same city as it was and so
yes in a in a Detroit type situation
where people are leaving abandoned
houses and stuff and yes you do see a
certain level of you know the most
unfortunate of society wandering the
streets and some of them are mentally
ill many of them are using drugs and it
is dangerous I don't walk to work
anymore like I used to in San Francisco
so how long I'm able to put up with this
is a is an open question in our
household yeah the last time I was in
San Francisco was literally the day they
were announcing lockdowns for the first
time I was there to raise money for
locals on the day that the market was
crashing and I felt being in San
Francisco was sort of a metaphor for
that but all right so let's let's move
then from that Coast to where I am in
Florida where now obviously DeSantis
wins by 20 points he's got a the
Republicans have super majority there's
basically everything is working here do
you view what's going on here election
Integrity which is working
um do you view this uh experiment here
in Florida as sort of the blueprint of
what you could export throughout the
country
well I mean I mean I certainly am very
impressed
Florida it is truly impressive and even
with early voting they mastered it
you know the RNC really has not and I I
saw the chair yesterday claiming credit
for oh we did this we did that
um and and in fact you know it's it's
really State leadership that that makes
it happen RNC May provide Financial
Resources but it hasn't really provided
the training to do that
yeah I wish I could live in a utopian
you know Republican Paradise like
Florida with the tax rates and the you
know the wonderful
non-lockdown situation
but I wish that was California
um but yes I think it's very impressive
and Leadership does matter and um and so
uh Republicans can efficiently run a
state and and bring it back it's been
very impressive
what uh where do the presidential or
potential presidential candidates of 24
what kind of role do they play in I
guess what you're doing now and what you
would be doing if you actually win this
thing because obviously there's really
two things happening here there's
there's the Trump portion of this and
then there's this either maybe DeSantis
thing or just something that is not
Trump how does that factor in to what
you're doing right now and then what you
would do as the potential uh head of
this thing
so president Trump selected Rana Romney
McDaniel to become the chair in 2016. um
when reince priebus went to the White
House as his chief of staff some of the
White House some of the RNC staff went
to the White House and then
some of them are let go for various
reasons and they went back to the RNC so
it's basically been the same folks
running the show over there president
Trump endorsed Toronto in 2018 after we
had a disastrous election and again in
2020 after he lost the White House
so
um he has not weighed in on this
election cycle as yet although I saw a
report in the Associated Press a couple
of days ago that you know one of his top
advisors is quietly telling people he's
supporting the current leadership for a
fourth term so
I mean I'm one of President Trump's
lawyers and my Law Firm represents my
partner's represent him in several other
matters besides what I've done so
um
I I'm not going to change what I'm doing
based on that it's this is something
that comes from my heart to do it isn't
based on a particular candidate telling
me what to do so and I don't think it's
you know appropriate for a candidate for
this position to seek the endorsement of
a presidential candidate because the RNC
is meant to be neutral on these issues
so that is my commitment to voters
because we have people on both sides in
the RNC we have a lot of trump
supporters uh I was I have a two-time
trump voter and then we have some people
who are also two-time voters who want to
see something different and so you know
the voters in America are going to
decide that I'm not going to decide it
um so I don't think any of the other
candidates have weighed informally and
that's okay because I think that you
know we really need to see what
Republicans in the Grassroots want this
isn't a top-down party in my opinion
should not be and so I very much hope
that we have a Grassroots oriented
outcome to this election what's the
technical part of how you get elected
actually
how does the leader actually get elected
yeah we have a winter meeting of the RNC
in Dana Point California
and uh there are 168 voters there are 50
territory 50 states and six territories
each of them has three members a
National Committee man a National
Committee woman and a chair of the party
and so you have to you know you have to
lobby with each of those now if you're
the chair you can cut deals with people
based on resources that you have that's
just a fact some members are very upset
that I said that at the beginning of my
campaign hey guess what
some of them are shocked shocked to find
out that politics is happening in this
establishment yeah that's politics you
yeah you scratch my back and I'll
scratch yours you you change your vote
from Bob to Sue and I'll make sure
you're the head of that committee that's
that happens at the RNC since the
beginning of time but I don't have that
ability right because I'm not able to
hand out goodies so that's that's but I
have my ideas I have
millions of Republican voters who want
to see a change at the RNC and
ultimately the members of the RNC are
going to have to face re-election or
election themselves
and
there's going to be a question as to who
did you support in the 2022 2023
leadership race and so people are
publicly committed to the current share
before uh I entered the race and she had
committed as I mentioned to running only
for a third term and she said she was
out after that so it was kind of a
shocker to see her come out with this
long list of supporters but whatever I'm
not deterred um I think it's going to go
down to the wire uh we have major donors
calling me cold calling me I've never
spoke to them before members of Congress
United States senators and certainly
some members of the RNC who called me
before I called them saying thank God
you're running we really need to change
I support you how can I help you so it's
been pretty encouraging
yeah for the record I'd be happy to have
Rana on and I would treat her the exact
same way I'm treating you and ask the
same type of questions and all of that
stuff what do you think the argument is
what what is her main argument I mean
because we all thought this Red Wave was
coming and then it didn't come and they
barely got the house so it's like where
is the argument that you should stick
around for this as you described this
fourth term that was never supposed to
be
um
I'm really making you be a lawyer now
yes well I'm an ethical person so I will
present as being said by her team which
is she did a great job
um four million more Republicans turned
out than in the prior cycle
um
we won back some seats in different
states she's taking credit for that
she's taken credit for the wins in
Florida New York and California I I you
know I think you everyone who lives in
those states can make up their own mind
about that I will leave it at that
trying to be polite
um people like her personally and I
don't dislike her I'm not running
against her because of her personality
and uh you know quote unquote I did a
lot for your state that's really what
I'm hearing back I transferred X dollars
to your state I've offered to pay this I
offered to pay that it's some some of it
is transactional some of it is
relationship and some of it is so-called
loyalty some of it is I asked you first
I mean then one one argument is we
shouldn't change horses in the middle of
the race I mean what's the race here
we're like racing off a cliff as far as
I can tell we should definitely change
horses
sailing analogy is I'm a sailor is you
know if you if you're heading for the
Rocks you should definitely correct
cores maybe you need to reap the sails
if there's a storm happening and you
need to like definitely you know pull in
some of those sales so you don't you
know crash and I think that's you know
so that's the counter argument but you
asked me to say what she's saying yeah
steady I've done a great job
we should not change the course we're
already planning for this convention and
you know
we're doing great that's the message
do you actually think that the the DNC
is not as screwed up and all the all the
stuff that you just expressed
frustration with and how deals get done
and all that stuff that the DNC is not
as screwy or or are they just better at
the screwiness you know like if you were
to look at the FTX situation it's like
they got all the money basically I know
he also gave some to Republicans but he
was the second sandbag but freed the
second largest donor to Democrats and
then of course two days after the
election it all comes crashing down
meaning that they're just somehow better
at the public show and then we just move
on and you forget about all the
corruption something like that so the
Democrats are definitely not as screwy
as we are and I think they're not screwy
at all actually in the Democratic party
they raise money in a very disciplined
way and uh you know they do have their
little tiffs personality tips between
the squad and Nancy Pelosi but overall I
think they're very disciplined and now
for the first couple of years I was at
the RNC we would be cheering rah-rah
because we raise more money into the RNC
than the DNC Rises into the DNC and
they're quietly laughing because they
raised 10 times as much money as we do
but they raise it into the NAACP and the
ACLU and the Michigan welfare rights
Association and La Raza and La Familia
Vota those five organizations or
organizations that I'm up against in
court right now uh for for election
litigation that's not the DNC they have
dark money organizations that influence
our elections and help pick
right-wing candidates in moderate
districts and so that we just like we
are we're cooked we're thinking great we
selected this great Conservative
candidate
that that candidate can't win in that
state and so we're just like not even
talking about that so their their
monetary ecosystem is far superior to
ours and they're very disciplined and we
are not and we need to get smart
all right give me your final pitch and
where do you want to send people to to
find out more
Dylan for rnc.com
d-h-i-l-l-o-n-f-o-r-rnc.com and you know
please if you are interested in
supporting us
Reach Out politely to the three members
of the RNC in your District do not call
them names uh some of them are very
shocked to hear from voters uh and uh
and importantly if you're a Precinct
committee man or a state party delegate
and you play a role in a state party
call for a vote of who should be the
next leader of the RNC that happened in
Texas and Arizona in a standing vote in
Tennessee and they all support change
overwhelmingly and so that's been
happening all over the time Harmony I
obviously wish you a lot of luck I also
wish you a Merry Christmas and uh we
shall see
absolutely thanks for having me Dave
my pleasure if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of mindless
dribble check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell